absolument parler vous avez pris votre
téléphone d'accord sans le consentement
du chauffeur à l'intérieur je vous
rappelle que c'est son commerce
c'est-à-dire que si je veux pas vous
filmez dans le domaine privé je vous
rappelle que c'est l'article 9 du code
civil qui vous interdit de filmer dans
un endroit privé déjà entendu excuse-moi
parce que vous faites très bien que ça
va pas le faire ensuite je vous rappelle
que lui il est pas censé savoir que vous
le filmez vous prenez votre téléphone
vous commencez à appeler votre
communauté on a l'impression que c'est
le drama buzz de la semaine c'est à dire
voilà je vais faire un truc sur le dos
du VTC
maintenant moi je vous le dis il y a un
moment on voit Sarah fraisou on voit un
tel on vous voit vous c'est toujours la
même phrase le rapport c'est je suis une
star vous ne savez pas qui je suis
excusez-moi vous êtes juste
[Applaudissements]
tu sais on a prêté tu vois le VTC
jamais ces gens là c'est toi qui met de
la maison
tu es une star tant mieux pour toi c'est
bien toi tu l'as dit tu l'as pas dit tu
peux le dire c'est pas un problème mais
derrière
je risque de vous déconnecter
syndicaliste c'est ça qu'on dit des VTC
représentant syndicat à quel moment on a
le droit de forcer
un client de descendre du véhicule de
force
donc c'est une prestation il est
indépendant si un moment il voit que il
risque d'avoir une situation
conflictuelle
c'est mieux qu'on arrête la prestation
mais vous de quel droit vous dites je
reste dans le véhicule
c'est la vérité excusez-moi mais à quel
moment de quel droit vous dites à un
chauffeur je vous prends d'otage je
reste là et faites ce que vous avez à
faire non si vous voulez éviter une
situation conflictuelle d'un autre
humeur sortez si vous sentez que vous
allez vous concrétisez vous dites ouais
mais je suis je me suis senti en
situation
a commencé à être agressif avec moi et
je me sentais c'était simple Guillaume
c'est pas une agression ce que tu as
vécu les mots ont un sens une agression
c'est quand on se fait frapper il y a
des gens qui sont nés
ce que je vois c'est qu'on a ici deux
personnes sur ce plateau il y a une
personne qui est pas contente d'être là
qui serait mieux en train de bosser qui
est obligé de se justifier qu'il se lève
tôt le matin pour travailler dur et une
autre personne qui est très contente
d'être toi qui n'a rien à faire
ça
du tout du tout du tout
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes partis avec manifestation pour
faire quoi finalement pour venir faire
votre Story et partir
que en fait moi je trouve ça scandaleux
en fait on est en train de normaliser la
violence
vous m'avez portez vous m'avez vous
m'avez forcé à descendre du véhicule
donc physiquement déjà vous m'avez tous
les jours
quand mon téléphone par terre oui parce
que vous n'avez cassé mon téléphone par
terre au moment où il a récupéré mon
téléphone et qu'il a cassé par terre il
m'a il m'a arraché du véhicule mais
vraiment comme ça et il m'a jeté